sécurité sociale madame la ministre est
malade et vous ne prescrivent est pas le
bon remède pire vous aggravé le mal vous
remettez en cause plusieurs principes
fondamentaux qui constitue à nos yeux le
coeur de notre système de protection
sociale
mettez fin à l'autonomie d'insécurité
sociale on ne respectant pas la loi veil
de 1994 et en la privant de près de 3
milliards d'euros
avec la mise en oeuvre des mesures
d'urgence économique et social en
réponse à la crise des jets et jaune par
ailleurs vous mettez fin à son
universalité en matière de politique
familiale alors que la branche famille
est excédentaire
vous ne saisissez pas cette opportunité
pour relancer la politique familiale et
redonner confiance aux familles bien au
contraire ou persévérer dans la casse
déjà mises en place depuis plusieurs
années de notre politique familiale en
prévoyant le quasi gel des aides aux
familles enfin les décisions du
gouvernement en matière de retraite nous
laisse pantois
quant à sa volonté de ramener
l'équilibré du système à court terme à
question madame la ministre est la
suivante gouvernement entente il
uniquement agir sur le levier de la
baisse des pensions d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
[Applaudissements]